[Applause]
hey
i don't see it
are you [ __ ] okay she linked the
article or stated police scotland said
that they would is that part in quotes
or not i just want to make sure you know
yeah is that part in quotes or is it
okay yeah that's incredible
you guys almost got it wrong that's
crazy yeah so the scottish point so the
scottish police said that if there's a
male rape suspect who says who insists
no identifies a woman a woman even if he
hasn't legally changed his guys
struggling right now
shifty do i have coffee yo
dance [ __ ]
so police scotland yeah said they would
allow a male rape suspect if he insists
on identifying as a woman to do so even
if he hasn't legally changed his gender
to be fair if there's one country where
the men could easily identify
as a woman as a woman yeah keep going it
might be my people it might be the
scottish people it's very progressive
they're already dressed like it they're
dressed like it number one with the
kilts yeah and also facially
do you think scottish men are feminine
no i don't think that's what he's saying
it's the other way i don't think it's
the other way
more scottish policing right now
i think you know exactly what i'm trying
to say
these scottish birds man
some ugly ducks
what is that wrong they're not indian
okay so
basically she's saying that uh she
disagrees that you should be able to
identify as
a woman a woman once you are accused of
rape yes because then you're going to be
housed in a female jail or prison yes
where there's more women than you could
potentially raise yes
interesting i think if there's one group
of people that were like yeah maybe you
don't need all the rights it's rape
suspects
i also think they can help you in court
too who if you're getting tried and they
have to keep on referring to you as she
i'm not saying transgender people are
raping people but i'm saying if you rape
someone and got caught you're like oh
there's an advantage to me legally if i
say i'm a woman like when guys will
pretend to be way older than they are
like remember harvey weinstein did this
or i think cosby did the same thing like
in court he's like in a walker he's like
oh yeah he's gonna feel bad for you and
like he's slack-jawed and then they see
him two days before the store and he's
just like walking around totally fine
yeah but that's because we feel bad for
old people but if you get into do we
feel bad for [ __ ] no but you get
into court though and then you see them
as well this woman was raped by the
other woman and you're like oh you're
like howdy raper yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he raped her
oh wow and i wonder if that can reduce
the sentence like should it be 25 years
should be life death penalty you're like
ah
i mean if you're a dude
in prison as a rapist oftentimes you're
either raped or murdered yeah you don't
have a great time yes not a great time
you'd probably have a better time in a
female prison yeah yes so for
self-preservation it makes sense yes
and you haven't legally changed your
gender so you could just say it
and then how do you legally change your
gender like
well you go through gender
reconstructive surgery no you don't have
to have the surgery you could just say
you identify them yeah but you could i'm
sure there's a legal process like you
just put on your [ __ ] birth
certificate or whatever like you're
licensed but it's like do you really
need to do that we're going to make them
do that yeah yeah
yeah if you're about that life yeah you
gotta go this is what you said last
night you're like i could never be trans
cause i don't do the paperwork yeah i
couldn't
stay consistent 100 i did feel that way
the paperwork is crazy yeah i'd rather
chop my [ __ ] off of my body than
actually do the paperwork
i would yeah you gotta do either or how
about that yeah one other two and you
know what i would do one hundred percent
chop the chop the [ __ ] without a doubt
cut the [ __ ] without a [ __ ] just did
not go to the dmv one day if you don't
change another paperwork with no [ __ ]
you're still a dude bro yeah you wanna
know something crazy
my girl walked in the room and i was on
the bed but naked after a shower and i
was just sitting like this
and she walked in from that and my balls
were hanging out the back but my dick
was hanging out the front so i just
looked like a bulldog i just had these
balls that were squeezed up and hanging
and she just walked in the room and she
just went
and walked out of the room
[Laughter]
what do you do that's absolutely the
same
though say again that's insane you could
do that then i could do that my [ __ ]
doesn't hang like that what balls to
hang out the back
side my [ __ ] is mostly in the
back that is hanging out the back yeah
yeah
you never had the balls hang out the
back door you never took a [ __ ] hit your
balls on the way down
his balls ain't dropped yet oh yeah you
still got young balls yeah i don't know
that's just like a peach dog nah you
gotta have them old balls your boy got
old balls though she's some long-ass
balls larry i got a long ball there all
right guys we're gonna take a break from
this exclusive patreon clip you can get
the whole episode at patreon.com
flagrant2 join [ __ ] army but right
now look we are all adults here and i
know some of us choose to use nicotine
to relax focus or just unwind after a
long day lucy is a modern oral nicotine
company that makes nicotine gum lozenges
and pouches for adults who are looking
for the best most responsible way to
consume their nicotine it's a new year
why not start it out by switching to a
new nicotine product that you can feel
good about okay i'm telling you this is
the best it's the best on the planet the
flavor's on the best it tastes the best
the options are absolutely the best now
if you enjoy using nicotine you should
definitely check out lucy's product at
lucy.co
that's
l-u-c-y.co and use the promo code
flagrant at checkout all right also i
have to read this as a disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical
remember if you're interested in a
better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.com
and be sure to use the promo code
flagrant now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip do they ever
switch sides you think yeah all the time
do you tell them i switch them
no that's a that's a [ __ ]
sticky thing yeah i had a friend had to
go to the hospital yeah get surgery i
could spend mine
mine are on some sort of gyro or
something like that
you're like a lazy susan just yeah
you don't like those bmx bikes you just
flip the handlebars like that
like a trick sometimes they'll do it as
a parlor trick in the parlor only
push them up real tight and then just
let them go and then let them spin right
down
yeah no absolutely back someone like
that yeah
when i'm coming only
did you ever hold your balls and watch
it i can't just break it everywhere i
get messy do you want to bring your
balls around like is this sock full of
soap you ever do that a sock full of
soap yeah yeah like a prison thing yeah
you're just like spinning around like
i don't know no i don't do that i don't
have that i don't have that length but i
do knot them up sometimes you go little
knot them up and you squeeze them like a
stress ball yeah you squeeze them like
and just have them like poking out the
top right here
you never do that yeah squeeze them nice
and hard that's not fair girls judges
for that yeah these girls are hating
dude
you know like you don't squeeze your
[ __ ] all up
jk rowling yeah yeah
so jk rowling dude i mean i she is a
real obsession with these [ __ ] man
yeah she doubled down so she tweeted out
wars peace freedom slavery ignorance and
strength penis people who raped you as a
woman so here's the thing
penis individual
is better better
talk
the same thing that's happening with
dave chappelle is happening with jk
rowling
jk rowling is universally loved
right like i think she crosses political
spectrum as well hey conservatives love
her liberals love her now that's for
sure well before the politics right when
she's just like the writer of the most
fascinating uh group of books that kids
have ever read maybe in history i mean
people kids are obsessed with these
[ __ ] books adults are obsessed with
these books the fran billion dollar
franchise etc everybody loves her
there's no one that doesn't love her
she has this opinion
that immediately
irks
a decent percentage of the population
and they're vocal about it and i think
it's hard for her to come to grips with
not being loved by a specific group of
people the same thing with chappelle
it's like everyone loves chappelle who
doesn't love chappelle oh interesting
everyone loves belle and now there's one
tiny little group of people that doesn't
love him and he's like
i need to reconcile this
you guys are wrong
you guys have [ __ ] this up trust me i
am right i am funny everyone loves me i
think this is just a function of being
unanimously loved and supported like
both of them were there were very few
people who didn't love chappelle and
even fewer they didn't love jk rowling i
think the difference with her and the
issue that she has is that her fan base
are people that are sympathetic to trans
issues like she literally wrote a book
about like acceptance and that like
you're a kid that's born into a family
that doesn't really love you or accept
you and that there's something about you
when you're born that feels different
and you're not like other people and
like you have this internal thing that
you're trying to figure out and then you
actually take go on a journey where you
find all your friends and blah blah that
book make you feel better all the people
that read the book they were like bro
this is amazing this is me yeah i'm an
outcast i'm not excited about my family
but i'm actually special i'm actually a
wizard the whole time yeah and now she's
like eh don't be trans though yeah
all of her fans that are like oh i love
this book because i felt like i was
different and now you're ostracizing
people that are different it's how her
audience feels
some people in her audience yeah i think
there's a lot of people in our audience
that also maybe feel that way about
trans people and they're like well she
wasn't talking about trans people when
she said that in the book yeah she was
just talking about me i feel different
from my brothers and sisters yeah
everybody feels a little bit like an
outcast in their family i remember
hearing somewhere that like kids who
read harry potter growing up are less
prejudiced though which it makes sense
if you read that book and there's such
an impact on people who read it yeah
that you're like but then all of a
sudden it just uh undercuts everything
that you thought you got from these
books yeah if one group of people isn't
accepted to mark's point yeah i'm just
saying like and and i don't want to go
all [ __ ] seth rogen here but like
this is probably happening in like one
case
in a random part of scotland
this is not a uh what is it an epidemic
yeah right of like rapists going around
saying that they're women so they go to
female jail now they shouldn't be able
to do it i think it's ridiculous don't
get me wrong they shouldn't be able to
but because she has this trans issue
she's now highlighting these really
small stories that barely ever happened
yeah where she would never have talked
about this before it's not like she
talked about trans stuff her whole life
right she would never talk about this
before but because now it's becoming her
war that she needs to win
oh i'm going to go and look at every
single she's going ben shapiro on it
yeah she'll find every single article
that fits
how many different ways of trans does
she have a google alert for
because she's finding all these stories
yeah but it's also less personal
i was right like me again it's also
legislative and for some reason that
always bothers people more like the
potential of it happening is more of a
problem than the reality of it happening
if it happened in the past she would
have a problem with it but the potential
that it could happen oh [ __ ] it could
happen because you don't know how many
times it could happen it could happen
all the time every rapist could say i'm
a woman and then what they're tried as a
woman and then they don't get the
punishment that they deserve blah blah
blah so in the same way the trans
bathroom thing when it became a none of
us have seen a trans person in the
bathroom but people were like dude what
it's gonna be people were scared like
it's gonna be [ __ ] mayhem and my
kid's gonna see my daughter's gonna see
dicks in the women's bathroom and blah
blah blah because everybody wants to do
whatever they wanna do when it's
legislative your brain goes to the the
uh most problematic scenario in your
mind
so you freak the [ __ ] out
if this if there was one case of this
happening she probably still would have
tweeted but i don't think she would have
felt it as much or like felt the need to
tweet as much she might not have yeah no
one ever complains when like say if
there's a dad with his little daughter
by themselves like that he brings her to
the woman's restroom to use the bathroom
and no one complains about him entering
the restroom really yeah
that that should happen i've seen that
but doesn't he bring her to the men's
restaurant no i think he brings us to
the women's though no i bring him never
since
yeah off
but because i would be like why are you
going to that one family yeah
going ours with the boys yeah take her
to the stall nobody's looking yeah okay
you just creeping around a women's
restroom and using your kid as an excuse
yeah so then the mother brings the son
to
and the woman's right yeah you remember
that as a kid no i remember my mom
bringing me the girls oh yeah yeah i
[ __ ] every girl in a woman's restroom
he was [ __ ] all them girls yeah yeah
you [ __ ] so much i stopped [ __ ] from
three to 31.
that's just time when i got too old my
mom brought me in and then like she was
in the stall and then just some girl was
like why are you in here
i swear to god i was like 12 and i was
like i don't know i've had my mom's been
there
well it never happened again i'm sorry
this came out oh
someone's gonna steal you at 12. i guess
i don't know homeschool man a male 12
year old yeah i think she was just like
yeah come on let's go you're with me i
think i had a growth spurt that day also
maybe day yeah that day
so that's homeschool [ __ ] cause when you
go to school you start using the
bathroom on your own at [ __ ] six
you're just going to the bathroom yeah
nobody's with you so the public bathroom
is six
that's what it is that's what school is
bro that [ __ ] ain't a private bathroom
yeah school but you go to the mall
yeah if i'm doing it at school i'm gonna
go to the mall who gives a [ __ ] mom i'm
not gonna follow me she'll follow me six
years old at the moment yeah dog taking
big [ __ ] just pissing and [ __ ]
pissing and [ __ ] i don't know that's
him six years old seems great [ __ ] 12
years old is crazy
it's scary
did you stop breastfeeding at nine and a
half yeah she does look like a long haul
bruh
[Applause]
what up people you just watch a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you